verbs are the driving force of any
language
as words of action verbs help us
describe what's happening
what we're doing what we're saying what
we're thinking and much
much more verbs are so essential in fact
that there's not a language on earth
that does not have them
despite that it must be said that
essential does not at all imply
simple being words of action a verbs
need to be able to convey that action
across a massive variety of contexts
things that did happen things that will
happen things that might happen
things that are happening and things
that were happening when something
else happened just to name a few and
that's without
even mentioning who or what is actually
doing the thing itself to convey this
incredibly diverse range of actions
most languages use verb conjugations
which are ways of changing the form of a
verb
to match subject tense mood and
a variety of other things this means
that as a learner of a foreign language
you must not only memorize verbs and
their meanings but also a potentially
massive list of conjugations to
go along with them some languages have
harder conjugation systems
than others though certain languages
have no conjugations at all
but on average you'll find that learning
to use verbs well is one of the most
challenging aspects of learning any
language
hi i'm luke alomparello from
lucanapedo.com and today
i'd like to share a few tips and tricks
for learning to conjugate verbs
in your target language let's dive in so
how the heck do you learn to conjugate
verbs
back in 1996 when i first started
learning german i tried to learn grammar
the only way i knew how
by reading through grammar books this
was a technique i had learned when
studying latin at school so
i naively assumed that it would work for
german as well
so i got my hands on a very dusty and
very boring grammar book in german and
started trying to learn
as much as i could but the time a couple
of weeks had passed
i had already read through the majority
of the book and completed all the
exercises along the way
however all this work was not having the
effect on my german that i was hoping
for
instead of having a well-memorized
knowledge of things like german
daddy does the clenching tables and
h-2az
verb conjugation tables i was stunned to
find that nothing
was actually sticking in my brain i
remember
some things of course but most of what i
had absorbed from
the one book was just a confusing jumble
in my head
and at this point i was not only getting
discouraged but also terribly bored with
learning german
as a whole if sifting through grammar
books was what it took to learn german
why wasn't it working even after
spending hours upon hours doing
everything i could
to get the information to my brain well
it took me a while to figure it out
but now i know the reason why the human
brain was not
created to memorize grammar tables
think about that for a second if you
listen to a five-year-old kid speaking
his mother tongue you will quickly
realize that that kid has very little
trouble
if any conjugating most verbs the kid
just does it
and he does it well how does the child
know how to use verbs so well
do you think it's because he likes to
spend his time reading grammar textbooks
and doing conjugation exercises in his
own native language
of course not that's absurd the child
has likely
never even seen a grammar textbook in
his own life
and yet he conjugates verbs just fine
almost perfectly in fact this is
possible not because a child is smarter
or more intellectually equipped than you
a functioning adult but rather it is
possible
because the child learns language in a
completely
different way than you do while adults
try to learn by cramming
and drilling facts children learn
through massive
amounts of exposure in this way children
are like sponges
they don't actively go out of their way
to absorb what they need to absorb
when the child is exposed to useful
forms of language over and
over and over again the child learns
these forms instinctively
for children learning comes through
massive repetition of language
in context so to learn verbs like
children do
you need to do the same or something
similar don't focus on conjugation
tables which are selected curated forms
of language taken out of context
focus on using and reusing resources
that represent the language as
it is naturally used and you will absorb
the proper
verb forms over time personally my
favorite beginner resources for
absorbing natural language
are spoken dialogues with an
accompanying transcript
these dialogues naturally will be full
of verbs that are conjugated
appropriately
according to context so if you repeat
and review them
often enough you will soon learn what
form of the verb
matches that exact context over time
this exposure will help your brain
implicitly understand the patterns that
verbs in your target language follow
and you'll never have to mentally
consult a conjugation table
ever again here's a quick tip you can
use to really help your brain focus on
learning verbs
every time you see a verb in a text one
of your dialogues for example
use a highlighter to mark the word on
your page so that it stands out you can
even use different colors to categorize
verbs by tense for example which is
really helpful
when you're starting out in a language
as you gain more and more exposure to
natural language you will come across an
ever increasing number of verbs and word
forms you might be tempted to learn them
all to know them all so that you always
know just the right verb form for
any situation but do you really need to
know
all of the verbs to speak a language
well and what does it mean to
know a verb anyway does it mean that you
know all these forms
doesn't mean that you know how to
conjugate the verbs
in all its tenses aspects and moods
thankfully the answer is a resounding no
there are thousands upon thousands of
verbs in every language but
to speak well in everyday situations you
only need to master a tiny fraction of
them this reminds me of when i started
learning hungarian
hungarian has indeed a very complicated
system of grammatical cases
so difficult in fact that it is often
considered to be the most difficult
language to learn in all of europe
officially any hungarian verb or a noun
can be conjugated in more than a dozen
different ways depending on tense mood
definiteness and a number of other
factors if you were to try to learn
these forms through rote memorization
as with a conjugation table it would
take endless hours to not only learn the
dozens of verb forms but
also to keep them separate in your head
fortunately although a wide variety of
verb and noun forms
do exist in hungarian very few of these
forms are actually
in widespread use in daily life normal
people do not use every tense every
pronoun
every mood and every aspect of a verb
equally often
instead there's a small select number of
essential
verb forms that are common and a massive
quantity that are used sparingly
if at all so from the beginning you
should aim to focus on
only the most essential verbs and verb
forms and learn the rest
only as you need them and while
determining which verbs are essential
and which
are not may seem like a challenge it is
actually quite easy
essential verbs and verb forms are the
ones that you
and people you're learning from use
often verbs like to be
to think to do to have to go are verbs
that you'll come across
every day and that you'll need to master
quickly if you want to have effective
conversations
once you've mastered those everyday
verbs and others like them
then you can expand and learn the outer
forms the goal in the end
is not to know every verb in its
entirety but rather to build your
knowledge
and understanding of verbs and verb
forms
slowly and gradually over time have you
ever bought a thick
hefty grammar book only to bring it home
and look at it once or twice
if at all i've done it a number of times
in the days before the internet
thick grammar books were the only
grammar reference materials that
language learners had
so even if you learned through context
you would need to consult these books if
you had any questions or doubts
nowadays things are totally different
the internet has not only made language
learning quicker
and easier it has given us learners a
wide variety of different ways to
test and verify our understanding of
grammatical concepts without using
conjugation or
declaration tables my favorite way of
testing my understanding of a particular
grammar concept
is online grammar quizzes let's say
i'm learning french and i'm having
difficulty with conjugating verbs into
the subjunctive mood
i could try to immediately input french
subjunctive
into my favorite search engine and read
all i could on the topic but
that would be ineffective in fact it
would be just as dry and boring as if i
had looked up the subjunctive in a
grammar text
instead what i do is search online for
french subjunctive test or french
subjunctive quiz fortunately there are
lots of language learners who have taken
the time to develop short grammar
quizzes that
are freely available online these
quizzes
exist for nearly every popularly learned
language and specific quizzes
can be found for nearly every
grammatical concept within
those languages these quizzes and tests
are useful because they allow you to
immediately test your understanding of a
verb or a tense
mood aspect and see if you really know
how to use it well so that's what i do
follow me my example i search for a
french
subjunctive quiz and i take the quiz
first once i'm done with the quiz
i take a look at what i got wrong by
looking at the wrong answers i'm able to
learn
where the holes in my knowledge are then
based upon the
types of errors i made for example i
forget which verbs are regular in the
subjunctive
i then search online for detailed
explanation of the specific
grammatical concept i was having so
basically i go to google and type in
french subjective verb irregular
and read through the first few
explanations i find
at this point you may be wondering why
i'm choosing to test myself
first and look up explanations later the
answer is simpler than you think
grammatical explanations are often
difficult to understand if you try to
learn a grammatical topic by looking at
explanations first
you'll usually be exposed to a large
amount of information some of this
information you'll know
already some of it you will not have
learned yet and the rest you'll find
either confusing
or unnecessary taking a quiz first helps
you zero in on exactly which verb or
verb related concept you're having
trouble with so that it becomes much
easier to find and learn what you need
to
when you check a grammar book or website
not only that
but following this quiz first approach
will help you return to that implicit
exposure-based way of learning like
children do children do not limit
themselves to using verbs and language
forms
they have explicitly been taught instead
children actively experiment with
language and try to infer grammatical
patterns based on what
they already know and just like you a
child will get it wrong sometimes
it's not unusual for very young english
speakers to say
i go to the store or i see the dog what
they're doing is learning through trial
and error
eventually the children realize that i
goad is wrong
and they learn to say the correct i went
to learn to conjugate verbs well you
need to do this too
get exposure to lots of verb forms and
try to infer the correct grammatical
patterns from those forms
then use online quizzes to see if your
mental grammar
is correct more often than not you'll
need to make a few adjustments which
you'll be able to then
do with the help of a you know trusty
online grammar explanation
or even grammar book verbs are an
essential part
of any language if you want to express
yourself well
you need to learn to master verbs but
not in the way you might think
learning verse well does not come
through the explicit memorization of
verb tables and complex grammar
explanations as you may have been taught
in school
instead a healthy mastery of verbs comes
closely through
implicit learning which is developed
through massive amounts of exposure to
natural language this is how children
learn
and how you must choose to learn if you
want learning verbs to be anything other
than
a major headache find sources of natural
language that you enjoy
and learn from them over and over and
over again you'll encounter a large
amount of herbs
but with time you're gradually learn
which verbs
and verb forms are essential and useful
and which are not
use those essential verbs and try to
make them a part
of your active vocabulary use them often
and experiment when you're ready test
your knowledge through online quizzes
and other forms of feedback and then use
that feedback to help your grammar
references to fix any gaps in your
knowledge
with time and patience you'll know how
to conjugate verbs like a pro
and you'll never have to consult a
conjugation table ever
again if this video has been helpful to
you be sure to like subscribe and
leave a comment below also before you
leave don't forget to take a look at the
description box below for a link to more
interesting research
on the challenges of learning verbs in
addition to those research links
you'll find a link to my blog where i
share a detailed article
on this very same topic and as always
thanks for watching
[Music]
you